can we just quickly before we dive into
today's on this lessons properties this
morning like a whole hour and a half ago
I told you five properties do you think
we can name them you think we can do it
we did the reverse which means you
integrate in one direction integrate in
Reverse backwards do you get the
negative give me another one you know
the dummy property right so if you've
got a definite integral doesn't matter
what I'm label is on the variable you
can change it for anything you like
another one okay see the treats you got
audit even functions and we've got this
two results are in from negative a to a
what's the roundup probably okay which
is the weird day which is when you are
actually doing part of the interval in
reverse order right so that's the f of X
F of minus x1 and the last one is well
also this is a reflective property which
we saw has nothing to do with
symmetrical functions but if you take a
function and you flip it around so that
you can integrate it over a.m. with a
different a minus X instead of X okay we
use we actually spent the lion's share
about time and get a pressure that
applied minute so this lesson going to
show you too long one of them I alluded
to last time and hopefully she doesn't
say the name you look but we want to
state it rigorously so in the next one
is the piecewise property so the
piecewise property is to say this is an
area I can consider one interval as two
different intervals or as many intervals
as I'll I sliced into pieces okay so for
instance if I have an integral from A to
B of some function then if I like I can
say well let's slice it at some point in
the middle between a and B actually
doesn't middles for me the wrong way
just because it can be anywhere in
between right I think they're note to 1
and 1 to 100 and that's the same as not
to 100 okay so I'm gonna state that like
this I'm gonna call it m for like you
know middle midway in between okay same
function
and then you do the remainder however
much is left up to the end settin em to
a B of the same functions and even
though you can sort of finagle around to
work in other ways we tend to say it for
this inequality we tend to what they've
taught in water because otherwise is
just confusing okay so the piecewise
property like I said we used it
informally in some of Chris we looked at
for for slice up integrals however you
like if it's convenient to you the last
one
that's what we call the limit property
or what I call them is property now
again this is what I sort of mentioned
before what we're gonna actually
demonstrate it this is when you have an
integral like such but the integrand is
not necessarily defined at your boundary
values okay and that's read you like
sort of taking one of the questions you
had to do in one of the exercises I
believe was one on a square root of four
minus x squared I think okay and so what
this thing looks like is well the square
root of four minus x squared that's a
much like no matter what take what shape
is that
that's a semicircle right so if I've got
x equals negative 2 and x equals 2 the
semicircle looks like this and then
you're taking we've seen this before if
you're doing the reciprocal function
okay there's a easy spot which is to say
up there right up there what is that
value
on this this is two so you take the
reciprocal of 2 which is haha so there's
1 so 1/2 is there ok because this thing
is symmetrical as this gets smaller and
smaller which is the denominator the
whole function gets bigger big up and of
course it's an even function so you can
exam ok now this function the one on the
square root of 4 minus x squared is not
defined at negative 2 & 2 but if I was
the integrate this with respect to X as
with easy function what is that that's
sine inverse of X 1/2 which is defined
at negative 2 & 2 so you have to be
careful in this but the reason that I
can therefore work out what this area is
even though it's what we call unbounded
is because if you're careful with your
limits it works just fine because think
about this wave right if I just think
you got one half of this because you can
just think about one half and double it
okay think about what happens as I got
go from say from naught to I don't know
call it common because your upper
boundary okay and as B approaches to
produce what is happening as I get
closer and closer to what's happening to
this area as I approach okay it's even
though up here it's like oh it's going
off to infinity but if you think about
these rectangles because that's what
integrals are about the rectangles are
also infinitesimally thin right so in
fact just like infinite geometric series
which go on forever they go on forever
in such a way that they still approach
they still converge to something okay so
if the limit is well-defined your
integrand doesn't need to be defined
that's kind of weird
okay so just state that formally here's
the way we're gonna say okay the
integral from A to B of some function
I can state that out if one or both of
my integrals are not defined then I'm
going to use limit notation to help me
so for instance suppose my suppose my
upper boundary is not to fight okay I'll
let take advantage of this piecewise
thing I'm gonna say well if the lower
boundary is defined just go from a to
you know some point in there the nut
bits okay
of your function and then when you're
dealing with the other part clearly
because I ended this interval at n the
next interval has to actually I need a
bit more space the next interval has to
start and am sorry I just need a little
bit more brutal but yeah right because I
want to sort of avoid the fact that this
B right it's like what's it going to be
equal to I'm going to use a limit so I'm
just gonna say just go to go to you
right whatever that might be and we'll
see what happens as u approaches B does
that make sense so if you're like doing
it I don't feel comfortable well I think
something like this when neither of
these values are defined just think
about what happens as you get closer and
if it's well-defined if it converges
then you just say that's what it equals
do okay so I'm gonna say this right so
this line right is the same as this
length or another way you could say is
you can just substitute so I'm gonna
actually give you a whole different way
a whole series of doing this I can just
not worry about dividing it up I can
just say let's go from a to you as you
approach is B right
that's kind of a condensed way of saying
it but this is kind of happening in the
background right or one more way if it's
not the upper boundary that's causing
you problems if it's the lower battery
that's causing you problems what should
I do
yeah okay yeah yeah yeah that's right
so I'm gonna go from you I'm gonna make
that the thing that approaches something
else the B is fine if it's well - fine
and you say well this time I want the
limit to approach a so all of these
things are the same they're all
different ways of slicing up the same
pie